how did every jepstein make his first
Millions before his private island and
operation with underage girls he
partnered with a guy named Stephen
hoffenberg the owner of a debt
collection agency called Towers
financial and together these two went
crazy they cooked the books making Tower
seem it was worth billions of dollars
instead of just Millions making it look
like this investment was going to the
moon the two traveled the world together
winding and dining investors selling
bonds to whoever was willing to buy from
major businesses to elderly retired
School teachers while they spent the
money on themselves luxury houses cars
planes yachts in the end they scammed
over 200 000 investors out of almost a
billion dollars in today's money it was
the biggest Ponzi scheme at the time and
just before they got caught jebstein
took off with his share leaving
hoffenberg to take the fall it's
suspected that jepstein would take this
money to fund his future endeavors and
that